hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
i'm overjoyed
for you to listen or watch this episode
this week we have the one and only
connor franta with me who you know
youtube extraordinaire
uh artist extraordinaire
runner extraordinaire uh my old buddy
he's got a new book out called house
fires which is his third book it's a
collection of short stories poetry
photography all these beautiful artistic
endeavors that he's grown into we talk
about the idea of growing and evolving
as an artist especially in the digital
space which is difficult to do it makes
many people uncomfortable lots of you
okay comments we talk about the tick
tock of it all we talk about uh
his
mother listening to his audiobook for
the first time among many many other
things conor is just such a joy to
listen to he's got such wise advice and
thoughts about the world um especially
one coming from beautiful artistic soul
can tell that also has a great sense of
humor so please enjoy this episode of
not too deep with connor franta
[Music]
connor connor connor connor connor
um
how many miles did you run today ah
got me got him uh i got eight in the
bank did you really
okay well what's your oh is that an
everyday thing are you running every day
for at least a minimum of a certain
amount i am well not a not a minimum i
feel like it's one of those things where
like most people who have like a gym
routine are like yeah i'll go for 30
minutes so for me it's like i'll go for
at least like five miles because that's
equivalent to what is that close to 30
minutes but honestly as soon as i get
going it's kind of hard to stop in a
weird way if you really get into that
rhythm and i'm like well what if i just
add on a mile what if i just add on two
miles i just kind of keep going well
because i wonder
have many thoughts and i have mentally
ill no no no you're mentally very
healthy and i think you're mentally
handling all of the chaos of thoughts
that we all have constantly i'm saying i
have so many questions but they're not
consolidated correctly enough
to make this flow it's gonna be chaos so
what i wonder because one i've noticed
obviously over the last couple years
that you have picked up a microphone in
many different ways
i love this little handheld microphone
connor in tiktok in youtube in your now
soft lunch podcast yes i was recording
an episode before this i just i like
yeah i like the long form well tell me
about that because you've come from
we've all come from this like hyper
edited hyper like let's curate
uh an essence of ourselves and now
you're kind of unediting yourself in a
way
uh
where did that come from and how does
that feel for you
i think it's this yearning to be
more who i actually am and who i
actually feel like i am
off camera and it's this it's striving
to because i mean as you know i feel
like as anybody knows nowadays that like
as soon as you turn on the camera you
just start like dancing you start
dancing yeah or or
putting question marks around your head
or or smiling awkward you just like
don't know how to act in front of a
camera naturally so i'm it's this it's
me striving to be a little bit closer to
who i think i actually am in some way
and it's still even you know an unedited
podcast i still feel find myself going
like that
and
well it's interesting because i i
am we're going to talk about your newest
book and all of that in a little bit but
the idea that like you started in this
world
in a very strictly collaborative sense
like you started in a collaboration
channel one of the first of now many and
now you've worked so individually that
it feels like you got that collaboration
out of your system and now you get to
just be yourself with your own thoughts
like explaining to people this is
linearly and succinctly how i think
about the world and things
is that purposeful like do you if the
idea of like collaboration stuff comes
up are you like i much prefer
my solitude my own thoughts which is why
i link it to the running so much because
i imagine that when you run you just
have this plethora of thoughts to you
and yourself for sure i mean i think it
was like a natural progression to work
to work uh as a team but then kind of
just have a strong desire for
individuality i think that's that seems
like exactly what happens within any
group whether it be like a one direction
or a youtube channel a group of
youtubers who can't sing who are
described as a boy band yes yes yes
still is the question of boys yeah we
are a band of boys and actually now it's
a band of boys and one women and one
woman
yeah
i can't wait for a reunion at some point
because it's going to be like an episode
of like dr phil or something
it'll be amazing i feel like it's
already been a little bit of that
basically at this point um but no yeah
so it was like a it was just a desire to
be an individual and to see
who i was as as myself and as an
individual and i i've been fighting with
this idea of like am i me or am i a
collection of everyone else around me
and you know what i mean and yes i do
know exactly what you mean and there's
this this like
there's nothing wrong with that but i do
wonder do i actually like this film or
am i just told to like it do i actually
like this type of music or have i just
been liking it because of that person
and there was this realization with many
aspects of my life in that way this this
realization of like who am i who do i
act what do i actually believe in
and
the curiosity that followed i guess has
been kind of the chaos of the last like
five years of my life i think that's so
beautiful i feel like i'm
i connect with that so deeply because
i'm also in that a bit of that world of
you know like you said earlier when you
when you spend years doing this like um
individual content creation where you
are the writer star producer marketing
team editor et cetera et cetera et
cetera uh it can feel very like um
uh
like oh my god look i can do all these
things but then at the same time you can
step back after years and go oh
i've become this persona this something
for everyone else this for external
validation that like who am i if i'm
left alone to my own uh thoughts
feelings opinions etc and how do i trust
myself to feel
what i actually feel uh yeah and then
you add in the layer of like
of of scrutiny or um judgment that comes
with having certain opinions on the
internet so then you're also editing
yourself to not say the real things you
don't want to potentially hurt someone's
feelings or potentially hurt like a
group of people's feelings like even i
was just filming a podcast today talking
about taylor swift and i'm like i have
nothing but good things to say but i
kept thinking what if i do say something
that's a little bit controversial even
though it's my real opinion and it's not
at all harmful but it's taken yeah as
something harmful i'm like is that
really that bad
a constant
game of
how do i care what other people think or
am i worried about the way other people
interpret what i think it's it's chaotic
but also i wonder for you like you said
that you are now just sitting down by
yourself kind of talking through your
feelings about things like one-man
therapy in a way for a bunch of people
to listen to at the other end of it if
that is like just sort of
untangling yeah this world in which you
live in on youtube for so long where you
get so
like woven into a specific type of
person now you're like what if i just
start peeling away these threads little
by little and see what's there
a little bit and like i can see how
it's like to some people that would be
either stressful or even concerning but
to me i've decided to look at
not even like an unraveling but like you
said kind of appealing appealing of the
onion or ogres we have players this is a
shrek reference
shrek was the first animated film to
ever win an oscar you should know that
fact it's important
this kid knows everything yeah i just
love my great green facts um
i think i think of that as like a fun
exciting journey and i think that that
is a revelation i've had in later on in
my life that you know the confusion and
the mess that we find ourselves in can
be enjoyable because it's it's normal
and it's human and that and it's just
going to be a part of life so you can
either like dread it or have fun with it
and i've decided to have fun with it
yeah you okay a couple things you one
have this beautiful balance between
this deep appreciation and affinity and
for aesthetic for art for beauty for
small nuanced
moments in life that are overlooked but
truly deeply beautiful
and then you also have this balance of
being very cheeky and funny and silly
about things and i think that's a great
truly a great
balance to all of it because it shows
i think this overall like growth i think
you can get so stuck in being one way or
the other or
having to be one way or the other that
to be able to exist in this like paradox
of
taking things seriously and also seeing
the comedy is
very revelatory i think and so anyone
that's scared of what you're doing i
think they're just not ready to grow up
that's what i tell myself when i think
about it late at night i'm like it's
them it's not me
it could never be me but that's the
crazy thing and i'm sure you get so many
comments and i've seen you respond to
some stuff on tick tock which kills me
when you respond so deadpan to people
being like uh idolizing you as what you
were versus
i love to my favorite is the no heart so
if someone says like are you okay i go
no
like
it kills me i love i i've really
embraced that type of response to public
comments because it's hilarious i think
it's fantastic but okay
uh let's i think maybe this is in line
with that the the new book house fires
which if you just google house fires
brings up many different results for me
it's a little girl watching the house on
fire that's me yeah i started the google
house fire and then it was just like
house fires in your neighborhood and i
was like well no no no that's not
necessarily what i need right now
um so this is described as and i quote
a raw depiction of a young man's
emotional warfare with his past the days
of wandering through modern times in
search of purpose and the electricity
flying from tomorrow's potential many
flowery words there are lots of
adjectives you know descriptors well
it's um it's a book of
poetry and photography
right and short essays yeah and sure
okay so how did you stumble on this as
being your third book and um
how has it been now that it's out in the
world with people
i think i got i so i've i've written
three books the first one was very much
memoir-esque which people people found
funny because you know as a 21-year-old
writing a memoir but
i i the more i've let that sit the more
i'm like people who are under 21 make
amazing art all the time why is this
like a funny concept yeah i was like
there are people who have grammys oscars
who were like 15 years old and they made
in unbelievably empowering music why
stifle creativity at a young age
so i've definitely had a little bit of a
[ __ ] you to people like that
stop stop stifling people's creativity
um and then from there i went to a
little bit more of a creative aspect
with note to the note to self where i
kind of approached writing a book as as
like a journal-esque a very open mind a
very
modern approach to
a book so it's it's relatively unedited
it's relatively raw it's not perfect and
it's intentionally so yeah so i kind of
combined both of those two approaches
into this new book
and you know it's little happenings
along the last five years of my life and
coincidentally my 20s
and how
confusing and turbulent it is to be just
like a person in today's overwhelming
world yeah but
it's it's alleviated with those moments
of uh of i guess like joyful curiosity
along the way and and with pretty
pictures and
fun and fun uh poetry
but i think that's
a beautiful way to not have to give the
whole story while also artistically
giving the whole story you know there is
such an essence online of um a pressure
to be completely transparent and to live
like a
you know a reality show of your whole
life all the time and to be able to give
the poetic essence of the emotions that
you felt without having to give the
details of what has maybe gone on
it's a beautiful way to do it yeah a lot
of us
have figured that like the the ones who
started in the beginning and who have
continued to to create and you know
continue to to stick with it and grow
and evolve with it i think have found
that way they found like that's the way
that if you want to survive online
that's how you do it is you
you pull back or you find ways to to
give but not to give everything
and that's how i found that it's a happy
happy balance of like being true to
myself and telling
the i guess like the
kind of the take away of the story but
not actually ever telling
every bit of the story or like never
telling the names within the story or
the real location sure like like music
like uh
yeah
they're um can i ask how the you got the
title
so the title was
like almost like most things or at least
for me i like am fully involved in the
full package every day oh i know the
aesthetic of it start to finish is a
connor franta joint thank you thank you
thank you and like the typography took
weeks the
the placement of that image took weeks
do we emboss or deboss this took weeks
like all that was i'm a nightmare
um but you're an artist you're an artist
i care i care a lot you're a night care
but yeah the house fires uh sort of came
to me because i had the word house
written down as something i wanted to
include in the title and i it just was
like borderline cheesy certain words
going along with it i didn't want it to
be some sort of like going home with me
or yeah yeah sitting at home it's a
little bit to mom's wooden kitchen sign
um so fire
and house together
came to me as this idea of like
a house is a safe place a fire is a
destructive object so throughout your
entire life you're kind of having to
build these homes and burn them down and
build these homes and burn them down
it's like a
constant growing of identity
and you're changing as you're going and
that could be seen as like devastation
or it could be seen as like a brand new
opportunity right in front of you
and it's this
beautiful metaphor that is kind of hard
to fully understand
death rebirth cycles they happen to us
constantly in so many different levels
and aspects of our lives i am this is
what i think about all the time right
now death rebirth everything is death
rebirth and again like some people have
been like that seems so sad i'm like to
me it seems beautiful and opportunistic
it doesn't seem it doesn't have to be
sad like you're thinking about it way
too literally it's not an actual house
fire nobody is dying you are not losing
both photographs and possessions it's
fine but it's also i mean you can get so
deep into it you can also stay like on
the surface because you could say you
know what is our idea of home where's
our idea of identity where do we find
our safe space and then as we grow up
that changes so you light that house on
fire you move on to something new or the
house gets
burned down for some capacity in a
metaphorical sense and then you move on
and you find a new home somewhere else
or like the idea of what you thought
your future was going to be which it'll
never fully be because you can't
actually know what's going to happen to
you along the way you have to constantly
like burn down that idea and rebuild the
idea as new things happen to you and
that's how i feel like my entire life
has been it's like i think i understand
it or i think i know what's going to
happen next year and then something
brand new occurs and again it's not it
doesn't have to be like this painful
loss it's a new beginning yep
ah all right we're gonna take a quick
break everyone marinate on that for a
little bit find your fire extinguishers
wherever they might be in your house and
marinate on that we'll be right back
with more not too deep
[Music]
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say two things a big thank
you for listening to the podcast uh if
you're a regular listener if this is
your first time listening welcome and
thank you
and uh second thing if you are enjoying
yourself here in this not too deep world
we've built and you'd like to leave us a
review that would be so wonderful if you
can go to the itunes store the app store
and leave us a lovely little review
comment how are you feeling good bad
otherwise maybe just good or otherwise
would be appreciated other than that
enjoy the podcast
but i will
now that we're back in connor
talk to you about the tick tock of all
of it oh nice hit me with it
what do you think about the tick tock of
all of it because i only stumbled on a
couple weeks ago maybe a couple months
ago because i don't understand time uh
to your tick tock and you're just on
there being hilarious and i was like oh
my god this connor's [ __ ] nailing
this i gotta figure this [ __ ] out thank
you that's sweet of you well okay so how
do you approach tic toc because as
someone that's been you know like we all
have been on all these other platforms
for so long you get this new one and you
go into it you've probably been on there
for a while now
what was your well you're like i'm going
to slide under the radar and just be
conor friend on tick tock but not really
tell anyone
exactly and i think that that's it was
totally unintentional like i was so
allergic to it for so long like i just i
just don't want to do another thing it
wasn't even that i didn't like it it was
like another thing i have to worry about
yeah god like and i see how much time
put people put into it you know
uploading like 10 times a day and i'm
like i can't do that i'll die which i
just want to give a caveat because some
people might hear that and be like
another you don't have to worry about it
you're all set whatever when you worked
in social media for a decade and your
whole entire job description is to be
available and making individual content
on these platforms you have to worry
about a new platform coming up it's like
if you're the ceo of a business and all
of a sudden they start a new franchise
in some town you have to go make sure
that that franchise represents your
business and like once you start
realizing what works like statistically
what works if you're ignoring it then
it's like why are you participating in
if you know that there's a better way to
do it yeah so me seeing that when tick
tock is like yeah it definitely works
better to upload 10 times a day and just
see what hits i'm like i don't have the
capacity to do that
so but so eventually i just got over it
and was using the app just to send tick
tocks to my friends like making my own
and then just sending them and
eventually one day i said oh this is
funny man i'll just upload it and then i
got like four million views and i'm like
oh
so like oh the magic is not gone from
old franco right i didn't think that i
just think oh he still got it
and then i also thought oh it can be
that simple it can be just something
that takes me two seconds to make and
it's fun and funny and if i upload it it
does well that's great but if i don't
who cares yeah and i was like oh it
could be just that simple couldn't it
yeah it really could be if i want it to
be we're so programmed that everything
has to be the best thing we've ever done
all the time constantly i know and like
yeah i've had a few ideas that a haven't
hit or ones that took longer than a
couple seconds to make and did hit but
like
i just i try not it's not on my it's not
on my calendar like youtube videos are
very much something i i think about
schedule in
and put effort in and tick tocks i like
to try not to
for fun and those are probably going to
be the ones that do so much better
because it's like in the beginning of
youtube when you didn't really care you
were doing it just for fun that's how
people could tell
and that's why i like it is i'm like wow
this is so refreshing to see people
being relatively like unedited which is
probably the right word for tick tock
but just like unfiltered yeah and weird
i like trying ideas yeah yeah
weird kind of weird humor is nice to
have have back
oh my gosh i know i haven't gotten there
yet but i would like to i'm still in the
face of i don't know how to do this and
i'm putting too much pressure on myself
to know exactly how to do this and not
letting myself be as free as they want
um
here's a question
if someone were to direct a movie about
your life or let's say some loose
essence artistic film loosely based on
your life
um who would you want to direct the
movie and it can't be you
and who would you want to play whatever
the loose version of you
would be that can't be you
it's tough because i i i love film film
is one of my many passions like i i see
movies every week i sit down and watch
movies every night if i can like i'm
always trying to to digest film because
i i think it informs
i think it is the reason why a lot of
people say i have a strong aesthetic is
because i'm i'm really conscious of that
yeah um
and like the first person that comes to
mind which is like a recent director i
really like is barry jenkins
um barry jenkins has done a bunch of
fantastic
uh fantastic films and he he just
captures kind of
uh i don't know like raw human moments
in a very a very beautiful way um you
should check out if beale street could
talk that's a great film by barry
jenkins um
and someone who could play me oh god
it's like i do i pick it based upon
looks alone or an actor i i actually
like
i know this is a very entrapment kind of
question um yeah i'm like the hottest
man in the world he can play me how
about that
okay let's see okay i'll limit it to
this uh timothy chamele
shyamala milan
uh
okay three options
timothy
salamander uh
tom hollandaise or ansel uh
egg egg whites that's egg whites um tom
hollandaise tim tim
samalander shyamalan
charmander yeah exactly one of those
three
in terms of like who who's acting i
think everyone's got like i actually
think all of them are great actors but
if i was gonna pick not based upon looks
and just based on acting um
tomato
tomato chalet is definitely in there for
me
you heard it here first y'all okay
all right connor i think you've answered
these questions long in the past but
we're gonna hit you with them again the
two questions that i ask every single
guest that is here on the podcast with
me the first is uh who alive or dead
would you most like to throw cold
spaghetti at
this one is a very current answer and i
don't know if it's going to stick in the
future or whenever this is uploaded but
currently it is november 15th yes and we
are
post-release of taylor swift's red
and i really think the entire internet
would
would shame me if i didn't say that jake
gyllenhaal deserves cold spaghetti
thrown at his face you shocked to hear
that we've had that answer today
it means it's great to hear that you
have guests with taste um well that kind
of i mean
thoughts on without being too thoughtful
who knows if you talked about this in
your personal podcast already uh in line
with the way we were talking about
earlier that you you handle you know
like your life story without being
specific to people places things
her doing something like that with being
loosely uh
overt about what the narrative is uh
what was your take on on seeing that
short film i'm curious
so the way i approached it in my podcast
is a way that i won't approach it here
i'll be a little bit more like
i i was conflicted because initially i
saw it i'm like poor guy 10 years later
and he's getting all this like
all these tomatoes thrown at his face
yeah but then i thought like
circumstantially
the uh it's not like she's re-releasing
the album to give him the middle finger
she's re-releasing it for
for the reason of you know she she had
due to get her artistic license back
sure and that was already the most
successful song on the album so like
coincidentally she's gonna probably make
a music video
so it's almost disingenuous for her to
make something
completely different relating to it so i
get it and i just like it was the fan
favorite that they asked for so it's
like she's giving the fans what they
want but she can't deny that this is
what the story was and they'll find
every easter egg in every single little
thing so if it's not true to
the original idea i think people will be
like what's going on do and i really
hope i really hope and this is this this
is a lesson for anybody who's ever in
any sort of situation where they're on
like the the jake gyllenhall side of it
if he reacts in a you know positive like
if he makes a short film himself giving
the scarf back to taylor swift genius
wow yes or even just a tick tock yes
honestly of him like having a red scarf
sobbing and like extending the olive
branch would be amazing and the best way
to respond to this all you have to do
honestly
would make
make a new tumbler that's just a picture
of him giving the scarf back
that's her sweet spot freaking tumblr
iconic it would be genius it would do so
well and maybe people wouldn't
necessarily forgive him but it does
alleviate like because he could he could
just choose to either have a negative
response or never respond which probably
isn't the best response yeah i think he
should he should pull orion reynolds to
do a hilarious commercial nobody asked
for
go there we go you heard it
okay
the other question i ask every single
guest on the podcast is to tell us your
worst pants shooting story or a bathroom
emergency
but you can only use three words or
three small phrases to describe the
event and as someone that runs
constantly i know you've got the runs
constantly
so
mine which hasn't been updated but
absolutely should uh is college jogging
front lawn
so i'm curious
what story might come to mind for you
that you can describe in three words
with three small phrases since i've last
been asked this question
which has been years so you don't know
when this happened but it is i i
definitely remembered i've remembered
more
i've been running my entire life i'm but
uh but a man of 29 so there are many
opportunities for opportunity there are
many opportunities for opportunities
so how can i describe the one that i
remembered and almost wanted to die just
thinking about it oh no oh no oh no okay
okay um let's say
you're a poet
expired
expired cheese
oh god
jet lag
[Laughter]
city jog
[Laughter]
did you know the cheese was expired
before or after of course not that's a
stupid [ __ ] question
i had no idea until
it was too late oh is that always the
case i hope your next book is called
expired cheese that's
expired dairy products
um
we'll talk offline it was dramatically
yeah i i don't want to ask any follow-up
questions i'll let everyone paint their
own pictures uh i'm a person
everyone's people
and we're all dealing doing the best we
can okay now we have a section of the
podcast called deep and hot where i ask
you a deep question that we have
prepared for you and for a hot take on
like kind of like a topic that we have
prepared for you
has anyone ever told you this section
reminds them of a casserole
a casserole like a midwestern cat deep
and hot
only someone from where you from
minnesota would say
as you said deep and hot one i thought
of explicit content and then two i was
like that reminds me of thanksgiving and
a castle roll so tis the season disney
season i'm planning at the moment so
it's all that's on my mind continue go
on okay here's your deep question that
we have prepared for you
what in your opinion is the goal of love
and this could be all different it's a
deep question it's a deep question
and this can be any type of love this
can be platonic love this can be a
romantic love this can be love for
nature for your prof for art for
whatever it might be
i feel like platonic and romantic love
you know true authentic love the goal of
it is just
to
to never
censor
your your true self in every way so to
never never feel like you have to hold
back on something you would say because
there is you know there is no judgment
or there is no
um it's not even that there is no
judgment it's just there's no fear of
what the judgment will do to you in any
way versus sometimes you won't say
something because you're like oh is that
too far but with someone that you love
you know that like even if it's too far
they know you enough to know that like
you didn't mean it you meant it a
certain way right it's an unconditional
kind of life yes definitely and i think
that that is both what i look for in
friendships and in romantic partners
yeah because that's the kind of love and
appreciated space that gives you a
chance to grow into more of your true
self when you can already start to plant
the seed of your true self around people
they're just going to help you grow
only be yourself when you're very
comfortable like a year in then you
reveal who you really are and you're
like i've been hiding this whole time
that's my joke always is that like ha ha
i pranked you this is who i really am
deal with it if you believe in marriage
it's as soon as you say i do then you
say i
[Applause]
here's
gotcha
oh
okay
hot take now you've kind of touched on
this already
um but your hot take
on
evolving as an artist which i think is
something you've been doing really
thoughtfully
whether you are
you know conscious or meticulously
trying to do it or not um i think people
like talked about this earlier you can
get stuck in your persona or this idea
or this brand of yourself um do you make
a conscious effort to evolve as an
artist or is it something that's just
kind of naturally happened the more you
try to be true to yourself
it's a it's a combination of the two um
there's definitely
um as you know as a virgo i i really do
love planning yeah
uh proud virgo
i am a proud virgo i am it's me jenna
marbles and co
uh
no i i so i definitely there is you know
an undeniable
strategy to anything from how i do the
dishes to how i upload a youtube video
but
i do think that there is this underlying
um process that we go through of just
like changing without realizing it or
adapting without realizing it
and i i wish
that
that was always met with with like the
change that people go through was always
met with like warmth and kindness versus
saying you've changed as if it's a bad
thing or you're different you're it
seems like you're you're different right
now versus that should be like oh look
they're they're they're thinking they're
conscious
they're a person who's trying to do
something different versus just
constantly existing as the same yeah
i with that i'm curious um
you know that house fires is out in the
world
what the reaction has been from people
that have either followed you for years
or they're new to to you and your art
what's that been like it's been great i
think that
what's nice um
is that like i was able to do a little
bit of a tour so i had like a little bit
of some meet and greets masks all that
kind of stuff and that was nice just
because
one i don't do that often let alone have
i done anything like that in the last
two years yeah um so it was just nice to
see
firsthand like the growth of my of
people that have watched me in a way and
people that would show up and they would
tell me their stories i used to watch
when i was 15. now i'm
you know in medical school
and to me it just
the most people have just been saying
they appreciate how vulnerable the work
is or how
how open i am in the work and
that was the goal honestly i went into
it saying like don't hold back on like
what you really feel i definitely you
know held back on like certain details
like we talked about but i didn't hold
back on how i actually feel about things
yeah
that's huge and then they put it out
there and let people read it
it's literally like letting them read
your diary it's wild a bit and it's so
weird with with literature for it to be
you know it's it you can't change it
really if there's a reprinting there is
but you can't go edit your instagram
description and change it out if it was
a little too much for people to handle a
little too spicy you know there's a
little too much chili in there i know
and i i think like i love the idea of
like it it being in a library and like
the world is on fire but it still is
like it's like the ash of the book still
exists and it's like 200 years later and
i'm like it's still there
a copy of house fires is in a house fire
have uh
did your family read it did you have
like a core group of people read it
first before you send it out into the
the real world
i get really nervous
sharing anything like that with anybody
so not many people read it ahead of time
um i let a lot of people read very
specific chapters and things and
you know it was a lot of
a lot of love around that but my mom was
on a road trip the other week and my mom
calls me and she goes oh good timing um
we just finished listening to your
audiobook and
i said
i mean this in the nicest way i can't
talk to you right now now that you've
informed me of that i actually need to
hang up this phone
i
don't that you gross weird um talk to
you later i love you i appreciate you
bye
i love you i need to establish some
boundaries really quickly but i love you
thank you so much i was like you can do
that just don't tell me about it please
oh god yeah it was a lot
have you talked since have we uh no
we're never talking again actually i
don't have a mother
i burned that bridge um in this house
fire i committed arson i literally left
their house on fire they aren't living
there anymore
uh
it sounds like it's going well i mean
anything that is that personal and that
emotional and that artistic is always
going to have a bit of um
yeah a lot to process after all of it
it's nice it's freeing again it's it's
it's a different it's a different way of
approaching things like that it could be
terrifying and it can be uncomfortable
or you could be
you know there's there's no reason to
fear the truth because it is what it is
there's no reason to run away from it
because it will always be your truth in
that moment even if it changes later on
it's like that was what i felt then i
can't i can't lie that is how i felt so
what's there to be afraid of
well that's another thing to be tofu and
marinade on for a little bit we're gonna
take one last break
when we get back uh we have a question
sent to us that you and i can work
together to give some very
unprofessional advice because you've
already given so much uh we'll be right
back with more not too deep
[Music]
uh okay connor we have a question sent
in to us that you and i can give some
professional and professional advice on
um this is
about friendship
um someone is writing him
saying how do i get over a friend
breakup not how to become friends again
just how to get over the breakup of it
which i think is a very interesting
and
first of all the fact that you're
writing about knowing that it's not like
a
we're going to get back together but
that this is maybe the end for now who
knows he's already a step into
accepting it in some capacity um but i'm
curious your thoughts conor if you have
a name i yeah it's it's tough because of
course i don't know
how long you were friends with this
person or like how it how it ended
because that's definitely important but
yeah i don't i mean it's it's a it's a
sad realization the older you get but
you do
go through
friend breakups or friend losses
like semi frequently of just like a
person who's in your life for a moment
and they're gone the next but that's
just just how it was or how it was meant
to be so you kind of
you know you just kind of have to look
at it as like it's a natural way of life
and it happens to everyone and you can
be sad that it's you can be sad that
it's over but just happy that it
happened
yeah i also think there's some
sort of peace that can be have for you
that it's if like you're realizing oh
this relationship i have with this
person isn't going to continue it can be
rationalized like i can't give this
person what they want the same way i'm
not getting what i want from this person
and
to
you know reconcile with that in some
capacity
is really liberating and freeing and
mature but also very difficult at the
same time but realizing like if you're
giving more than you're getting or if
that person is doing the flip-flop of it
like
i think that's what adulthood is is
realizing the ratios on energy give and
take it really is isn't it oh my god
well you you have a bit uh you just did
a bit about like information about your
20s because you are almost uh how far
are we out from 30. what what is that
november two months so i'm i'm 1 6 the
way through this this through 29.
okay so in your 29th year mm-hmm any
um
incredibly profound thoughts or
incredibly simplified thoughts that have
had a profound effect on you
um it kind of was like the
aftermath of how that video really
resonated with people i was shocked at
how many there's just like a lot of like
a lot of comments and a lot of like
lengthy comments too like full-on
stories of people at different positions
in their 20s
um and it it's just i wish that often in
my 20s i just didn't take things as
seriously as they were i made a video
about that last week of just
it's not it's not that things aren't
serious but i wish i didn't make it seem
like everything was the end of the world
always or
i let things
get me in such an emotional rut
sometimes and i feel like that happened
a lot during my 20s and then
if you asked me about what was that if
you were like oh yeah that one time you
were really sad like two months ago i'd
be like yeah i don't even remember what
it was about because it didn't really
matter it just seemed like it was the
end of the world so there's so many
things that i'm like just like chill
just chill if you can
this is why i think like we said earlier
that you being able to have a sense of
humor
along with your sensitivity
is extremely important and a
quintessential balance for any artist
any person that's putting themselves out
there publicly like you have to be able
to find the humor in the things that
seem incredibly
debilitating and devastating i mean to a
degree depending on what the specifics
are but you know the things that you
think is going to crash your world and
sometimes
you can uh find something
something oh for sure i mean like some
of the times where like
something devastating happened to me i
either break down or i break out in
laughter because it's so comical like
there was one day i had where um someone
tried to break into my house i got in a
car accident and i was supposed to get a
tattoo the same day and i was laughing
at how hilarious that entire cycle was
of me being like someone tried to break
into my house oh my god i'll get over it
it's fine and then i get into a car
accident on the way to get a permanent
tattoo on my body and i thought i am not
remembering this day the idea that i
would get something permanently on my
body and every time i looked at it i
would think like break it
break it and car accident and like all
of it was just so funny to me at the
very end of it but it could have been
debilitating if i would have allowed it
to be yeah did you ever get the tattoo
um no sadly i didn't i i mean i got the
best i got i got more tattoos but i
didn't get that specific one sadly but
okay okay that was the universe really
trying to tell you not to get that
tattoo i think that's kind of what i
said because i could have kept driving
the vehicle didn't need to like be fixed
that bad i could have kept driving but i
said
i um no thank you
i don't need that
i don't know if this emotional
rollercoaster is the ride i should be on
to put something permanent on my body
exactly and it's like that could have
sent me into a spiral but i just
in that moment i was like this is
comically horrible oh yeah well you can
zoom out a little bit on all of it um
connor we're getting to the end of the
podcast i can't thank you enough what is
on the horizons for you i know you just
had this book come out that will still
be you know in your ether promoting and
making sure people have in their hands
and their brains and mothers have it in
their audio book files
you can listen to it but don't tell me
yes
uh it's yeah it's a lot of
as you know it's like working on these
long-form projects you spend so much
time working on it that when it's
actually out you're like oh yeah the
journey kind of begins now so it's a lot
of a lot of promotion of it a lot of you
know reminding people they can
they can have it on any type of they can
have it in physical form they can have
it on a kindle an ipad they can listen
to the audiobook that take took me a
week to record all of that but beyond
that it's just you know it's just kind
of like living and creating making
youtube videos making tick tocks when i
feel about it i have a photo shoot for a
magazine next week that i'm
photographing and uh commercial that i'm
in the week after that so it's just like
fun
i love life but we haven't i mean we
haven't even touched on the idea that
you're a professional photographer on
top of all of this which blows my
freaking brains but it's so fun
but that's you're staying true to the
little flame of art inside of you and
going wherever the candle like uh blows
like you're like a candle in the wind
some might say
uh
connor for making time for us we like to
give a token of our appreciation for all
of our guests um and that is a
personalized horoscope from us to you
that melissa has put in the chat for you
if you'd like to read it aloud okay for
all of us
dear virgo maiden of the stars
your sign may bring about a stubbornness
in you that you already know the right
answer to a problem however there's
power in learning both sides of a
situation rather than opposing fights so
from now on let's say you play for both
teams
wait don't take the that the wrong way
yeah the stars are silly silly gooses
yep well both teams i mean
you never know i never know you never
know
connor where can people get the book if
they don't already have it where can
they listen to your
um newish podcasts where can they follow
you on tick tock all of the things um
well i've just changed all my usernames
to at made enough stars so you can
follow me
all socials
no your boys at connor franza on all
socials got them on lockdown
connor frantabooks.com for my book
anywhere in the world you can get it
there's tons of signed copies in india
and australia so you can get it kind of
anywhere and
wait are you still doing common culture
right now uh we're on a little bit of a
hiatus but there will be more coming
soon
great
i love the crypticness of it oh of
course there always is always plans um
congratulations and thank you so much
for talking to us about all this uh
follow this beautiful
budding artist hilarious human being
wherever he is and whatever he's doing
i'm obsessed thank you again connor and
we'll see uh you guys next time on
another episode not too deep
too goodbye too deep
not too deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry and
an extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music